chez les banques est ce que vous seriez
prêt à faire part à pour pour de
l'argent voilà pas par amour pour
l'argent c'est que vous n'êtes plus des
personnes vraiment plus sur l'argent que
sur l'amour donc c'est important de le
dire
mais là il pas repartir de france à lyon
un autre pays pour une autre aventure
non combien il vous faut parce que je
peux peut-être fois
[Rires]
tu peux peut-être pas peut-être parce
que je peux faire exclusion non mais
vraiment ça me dérange pas du tout je
peux vraiment pas y voir ce que je peux
faire un nom vous castaldi et je vais je
vais être franc je ne suis absolument
pas vénal à rien du tout balle arrêtée
avec le pas de regarder des bateaux sur
votre téléphone et bien sûr les salariés
regardent des bateaux des torches des
ferrari et lamborghini et va dire qu'il
n'est pas nouvelle vous voulez d'htc la
différence
[Rires]
c'est pas vrai
les yeux voilà ce qu'il en reste c'est
pas vrai nom n'a jamais adhéré et
mathieu cvo par gary hart journée c'est
mon jardin je l'un des bateaux et alors
tu rêves un dq tout cas est différent
enfin parce que c'est gratuit
oui à 400 mille balles le cul crois
exactement à mes vives à monter une
nouvelle monnaie virtuelle la beauté
oui gilles mois jusqu'au règne nu dans
les rues de paris
eh bien écoutez je vais vous gagnerez
jamais beaucoup d'argent je dis ça pour
les français qui le regarde et pour les
parisiens on a déjà amené d'algos on a
assez
ça y est on a déjà assez de mal comme ça
n'allait pas en rajouter vous gagnez le
moment j'ai pas beaucoup de choses parce
que j'ai pas mal besoin d'argent donc je
serai prête à montrer une partie de mon
corps par exemple alors
on a déjà amené balgau je l'aimé à
passer ensemble voilà oui encore et
ensemble du ça marcherait pour plus cher
ça marcherait oui ben voilà on aurait
l'impression vous savez les reportages
sur les nuits d'histoire
ces belles avec zoé genre coupe on
dirait les paires au portage sur les
nudistes convoyer les revenus sont rois
diffusée
sur téva achat opa ouais mon corps est
plus importante
non mais j'adore et voyez toujours le
mec au marché un qui va voi et alors ça
lui a commenté clémente il
mais ce collège et a toujours le mec il
est bon l'état l'a jamais quelle est la
bonne
idée de fond les fruits comme ça tu peux
aller me l'ont ils sont bosselées
c'est dégueulasse à décoller ils sont
tous contents d'être à poil au marché
non mais c'est un truc de fou tu avais
au passé tu l'auras pas de mec elle est
bonne
non pas du poisson
et
si on
mettait d'euros non
non pas ceux de jean yves cela merci
alors oui donc alors est ce qu'elle veut
et franck après quoi de son corps abbas
que vous voulez
demain ce que
m le prix peuvent aller chercher à
marquer quoi à bages et c'est spécial
pour vous ah mais oui bah bafin ah ouais
c'était pour que vous regardiez un petit
groupe
d'amis en dessous gilles verdez king of
peace
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une pépite à qui j j le coup de
magie vous êtes touché quand même par
j'ai touché céni daniel daniel a mis les
bouchées doubles
et voilà donc je peux je peux enfin si
vous êtes prêts à mettre combien pour
que je l'enlève pas
ça peut être drôle
veut-elle des billets ouais allez-y
mettez votre salaire de tpm people and
on a bon pour voir del moro nu oui ah
ouais là c'est plus drôle du tout
j'ai avalé bel effet pour beaucoup moins
alors beaucoup moins à lever le doigt il
sera prêt à payer visa oui moi pour
s'emballer quelques tweets jeu kane del
moro
[Rires]
il
ramène un nul c'est bien ça vous choque
dans la phrase
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais sans déconner jamais daniel
était chaude
quand est-ce qu'on est un petit scoop de
petites minutes il fallait en fait d'une
tour de table bien sûr et après voudra
on n'aura plus que vous voyez à bosser
en tout cas bravo mathieu
son doigt non oui pas il a profité de ne
pas être dans le prime hier à succès
pixels pour travailler sur les missions
d'aujourd'hui bravo mathieu oui qu'est
ce qui l'a le des précise
non mais on dirait vraiment lui on
dirait de l'amour qu'on a ouvre dans
l'édition mondiale comme on ne sait pas
ce qu'ils perdent complètement vite et a
toujours un mec comme ça dans ton clan
ton immeuble c'est qu'un pas ou qui
parlent à personne quel côté show l'an
passé sera dans les salles ses cheveux
gala ségala delphine tu ferais quoi toi
pas pour mais moi je suis pas du tout
intéressé par l'argent du mal à répondre
à la question
on va faire des choses mais par argent
ça mais je m'en fous totalement avec vos
conneries va baisser les salaires de
tout le monde
dans par amour je pourrais aller vivre à
l'étranger je pourrais arrêter de
travailler est choisi
par exemple pas là bas je peut vous
arrêter mais pour l'argent aérien
non ballon guillaume spots excusé auprès
de daniel cohen et les tweets ces deux
doigts coupe faim c'est ça la
voiture ajoute derrière on est connecté
il me parlait plus dans l'oreillette je
peux plus vous verrez merci
merci à les noces où l'aï je déconnais
papa est parti après partir d'oeuvres
d'art et jtc partez partez vous ne
servez à rien article merci bouh clément
guérin mais moi à la différence de benji
et de delphine suis extrêmement vénale
donc honnêtement c'est un no limit moi
j'adore latrines moyens
mais n'importe quoi on est je suis
totalement fan oui mais j'aime trop la
tude mois mais jacques wattez pmp xxl
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hmm hmm quoi je parle ken daniel mais ça
va
ça va sa culotte n'est pas un
supermarché
au nom n'est pas chez lidl
c'est carrefour auchan nommé comme ça
aurait été vraiment afin encore de quoi
gilles ça te choque beaucoup à mesure
tout de lui on dirait un petit enfant
mots des rebelles samedi pervers
ah c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai si tu savais
et c'est vrai que oui c'est
un diablotin on va le dire non je suis
quelqu'un de très sage et aucun problème
tout va bien et qu'elle a gelé mandela
bay l'on avait dit dire 24 mai gm s'est
[Rires]
alors dit 24
25 ans est presque puisque votre style
pas dans le projet non non non
j'aime les lélés grand baraqué poilus la
baisse
[Applaudissements]
duchaussoy
[Rires]
dommage mais pas poil vous je me suis
reconnu dans la description de daniel
quelques poils ici on va y arriver
c'est 50 euros un bounty
les mous
[Rires]
c'est une évidence en fait ça rit ouais
c'est vous et est il vrai que vous et
oiseaux menacés mais franchement si on
perd on a déjà connu un drame hier soir
c'est bon on va pas au quotidien pour
des drames tous les jours vous moi pour
cinq cent mille euros je me fais là la
coiffure de genton pour 500 millions
qu'est-ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] quand même
charge ou non non c'est pas évident pour
500 millions vous faites un truc qu'on
est ensemble quoi alors pour cinq cent
mille euros
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression qu'à ce rythme-là
daniel va être la plus riche de la mort
la daniel géraldine c'est votre cible
and on and on and on fait la chine très
gros baraqué poilus mais sinon semble
maintenant daniel mais je 300 milles et
je prends delphine ah oui d'accord alors
par contre j'aime bien venir là
pour d'affinage et pour le délire
vous jeu pour voir mon offre à la baisse
pour daniel
20 balais en ut
plairait le plus méritant mais couscous
auriez-vous par jean ba lui
franchement jolie miss ado limite cuir
non mais ça continue les fans je pense
ouais ouais as pas marre des photos
dénudées à chasser ben vrai compris
voilà quand vous voulez faire un compte
dix mois et vous
irez voir ces photos a pas mois ci pour
vraiment ah ben oui je suis un
peu trop les mauves ou très beau gosse
ah oui quand même ça va tranquille
[Applaudissements]
compagnie chez nous
oui bah alors là franchement quel succès
c'est castany la delphine qui le clip
daniel a été un grand écart c'est vrai
mais franchement oui c'est fou c'est pur
intérêt qu'il est là c'est assez dingue
c'est retour vers le futur faire d'un
charmant ou cyril site était de choisir
non mais
on n'allait pas du tout attirée par
l'odeur mais cette fois lui cette fois
ludique et très bonne sur le tour je
vous ai vu tomber de travers et les
mêmes galères et la sensualité qui se
dégage
et le n'y est pas opposée sexuelle voyez
vous avez des petites et ont très mignon
j'ai remarqué ça se noie bien dans les
poils
par contre on est tous au niveau de la
sexualité orange
j'ai dit tout à l'heure tu fais quoi ce
soir je sais pas pourquoi c'est une
blague elle va regarder césar ont fait
une soirée gay alors il a invité cinq
gains à coiffeurs et maquilleurs un
danseur chez du tout et il m'invitait
très gentiment pour les vents d est
absolument il a fait beau mano poli mais
elle est où ta femme avec nous bah ça
faisait partie de la bande
c'est fascinant qu'elle soit réglée pour
les césar sur sa femme qui s'appelle
jean marc en
eau la droite merci jean marc et merci à
être là merci